okay so uh today we got T.I rapper from
Atlanta going up on stage says TI goes
off after a joke is made about the
previous Scandal of weinsteining made
against him all right so this is the
video that initially came out
um so there's this community on stage
apparently made an allusion to what had
happened to him in the past TI being in
the crowd decided to lose his mind and
this will happen
there is nothing to charge me for 45
seconds
[Music]
absolutely
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right so that's the interesting
question
so she explains a greater context of
what had happened before
so I'm going to explain this one time
this is about what happened at one night
only at our bar on Edgewood with myself
and T.I TI came to the show it's about
over anyway it's open mic he comes he
does like 30 minutes
okay when you do an open mic usually
it's like five minutes that's why she
looked like that at the camera if you do
30 minutes no usually we don't care who
you are you do 30 minutes you're like
it's dragging it's an open mic I
disagree go ahead
disagree with what what have I said the
issue is not that he did five minutes to
30 minutes disagree on what I said
nothing [ __ ]
it's not the issues that they did 30
minutes
the issue is that TI did 30 minutes yeah
I understand so if a big name [ __ ]
comes through want to do 30 minutes
people don't give a [ __ ] I just said
that that why she did look what she
looked because it's T.I doing 30 minutes
I'm not saying no bro I just said what
happened and why she looked like that
because most people don't know how long
you take the what was the problem what
was the look for I just gave contact
that's all I did right right but what
I'm trying to say is she's not having an
issue with somebody coming to do 30
minutes specifically yeah is that T.I
who's been doing comedy for a year is
doing 30 minutes you know what I'm
trying to say it's like if Dave
Chappelle show through like [ __ ] like
this is what it is yeah but Dave
Chappelle's been doing comedy TI we
don't know that's the issue and yeah so
a lot of people a lot of people have had
an issue with ti over the last couple
years yeah the last two three years
because he started to stand up and
because he got his name it's kind of
like when Stormy Daniels started yeah a
lot of people yeah this [ __ ] sucks
because of the name yeah and so she out
here eating ass on stage but because
it's a special yeah absolutely yeah so
it's just that he's just I'm just saying
that because you said I disagree [ __ ]
with what what if I said that if you
play it back what you had said is that
the normally these communities come to
do five minutes TI did 30. that's what
she has an issue yeah okay no she don't
have an issue because it was T.I doing
it's fine now after he gets off stage
I'm going to the next I'm hosting I'm
talking about Meredith he keeps cutting
me off telling me to shut the [ __ ] up
call me all kind of heckling Me Okay
problem number two
if you go to a show and you heco
[ __ ]
listen a Heckle from the audience is one
thing comedians need to shut the [ __ ] up
during the show I've seen from you've
seen promoters talk in the back shut
your hat shut your [ __ ] mouth those are
trash promoters yes this is a comedian
thing it's like someone's going through
a set they got a flow they want to go
with their jokes yeah if you're a comic
in the bag trying to disrupt somebody
because when you come through it for
five minutes set you're trying to work
through the stuff the material when
someone heckles that's why it disrupts
the flow so you don't know if your jokes
are working or not because you've kind
of [ __ ] up the whole thing a comedian
doing that is worse because [ __ ] you
know what it is so this [ __ ] in
the back interrupting other Comics after
disrupting 430
garbage you just did 30 minutes and
you're not you're new with this bro and
then after that you're going to go to
the show that's you
and you
listen
comedian okay and you know how it is to
get hecklers you don't Heckler you don't
Heckle nobody whether you're on the show
or not if you touch the stage you graze
the stage and if you graze the stage
once in your life okay and you're a
Heckler and we come to find out that you
actually do stage
I've seen [ __ ] been barred from
from clubs for because of that you're a
comedian and you heckle
or you try to do this [ __ ] and you
heckle
ti ti is straight up loser for some of
this bro and that's the entitlement of
like being a rap artist something you
come to stand up and you own everything
it's like bruh iron your stripes too
yeah because you probably trash it stand
up yeah and it's not the same way if I
stay in a person wants to do rap
probably be garbage too but because I
have a big ass name yeah we'll go over
everybody nah be I stand on what I said
if you're a comedian anything's up for
jokes about me all day and I've been
laughing at some of it nothing's off
limits nobody's special stop
third thing
if you're a comedian and you cannot take
a joke you know what [ __ ] that you you
you're allowed not to take it you're
allowed not to take it you're you're
allowed to find some [ __ ] not funny
interrupting a [ __ ] while you do
boy if you don't get the [ __ ] out of
here if you do not get the [ __ ] and then
you you monopolize the whole [ __ ]
bruh you're not you're out of place
you're out of place this this this this
natural Lane it's crazy you're out of
place bro you out here disrupting
everybody else and you get upset when
you don't like what they say in
retaliation brother you instigated the
whole [ __ ] situation
you instigated that you mad because my
yeah is a whole clown bro he's the same
guy who went up after Godfrey did his
headlining set and did 30 minutes
huh Godfrey went up and did a set in
Atlanta
TI went up after him into 30 minutes and
Godfrey's like watch this guy going up
after me after I just headlined
after he headlines yay
you guys might not know this
close to the show did people come to see
the headliner that's what they're
excited for boom some random dude shows
up and closes the headline weekend show
that's unheard of like when stand up
like that's crazy you do that open mic
even Dave Chappelle won't do that so she
like that to come up after the headliner
that's insane
but that's just the entitlement of some
people it's like you'll get these people
out like again people feel like because
they feel some type of way they're
entitled to whatever they want TI is a
whole [ __ ] clown for this and the
people who be getting up on stage
running up on Comics because they don't
like what they said are whole ass clowns
too bro I really feel like this shit's
becoming more common yeah [ __ ]
gonna start rolling on stage people have
told folks that because you feel
something that means you're entitled to
some kind of response I'm gonna tell you
something bro don't step on the stage
don't step on the Stitch don't step on
the stage of nobody who raise stuff I'm
I'm done who raised y'all sit your ass
down shut the [ __ ] up and if you don't
and if you don't like the show you know
what you could do two things
shut the [ __ ] up
or not not a damn thing about it you
could leave you could leave you could
leave that's three you can leave you
either leave you shut the [ __ ] up or you
don't do a damn thing about it there you
go these are your options
yeah NTI you're really just doing this
because you're TI okay that's all but no
no hold on a whole ass clown for this
it's clown Behavior right there you
Heckle the [ __ ] whole show you
disrupt [ __ ] and then you mad
because people are retouched man if you
don't get the [ __ ] out of here I ain't
got nothing else to say with this
yeah stupid he heckles and then she clap
back see
he did this
now you want to get pissy about the
response you're a [ __ ] loser don't
play with me don't play with shut up
shut up but yeah those are
bro me you know me and me most comedians
make me cringe so [ __ ] hard with the
way that they act it shows Comics up on
stage these [ __ ] talking them back so
loud the audience can hear them yeah
it's like be respectful to people on
stage I gotta tell Comics to shut the
[ __ ] up be respect for them to shut the
[ __ ] up because bruh somebody's on stage
trying to work through this [ __ ] you you
[ __ ] heckle that's crazy
thousands listen if I'm running to show
you out you booted 100 you'll never be
allowed in my show again ever I've booty
people for much less I know what you
talking about you Echo you Heckle breath
Ruff even on the show I run I would
never make noise like that while the
community is performed because I know
you put your head cold and you yell some
[ __ ]
and then you get up on stage but they're
not gonna ban this thing because he's
royalty on me oh I would [ __ ] but I I
wouldn't pan it I wouldn't give a [ __ ]
you would never be like no you can't
come here man you can get the [ __ ] out
grab all your [ __ ] all your dudes get
the [ __ ] out yeah but you know a lot of
venues don't respect comedy no it's just
a vehicle for them to make their bars
yeah they just [ __ ] come in and
they take and whatever is on stage on
stage because I know plenty of comedy
clubs would have thrown this fool out
like a whole ass bum but they won't hear
oh to me this is I don't understand
people who do [ __ ] like that but anyway
so let us know what you guys think in
the comments below we want to hear from
you